في مكتب الجزيره احمد فضل احمد فضل بدايه
كيف يبدو الوضع في الخرطوم بحري حاليا
نعم بعد الاشتباكات التي وقعتها صباحا بين
الدعم السريع في عده مناطق في بحري يبدو
الان الوضع اكثر هدوءا من اطلاق نار متقطع
من حين الى اخر لوقت
لكن الاشياء في الامر ان حركه الاسواق
بدات اول ايام الهدنه الرابعه امس في في
النشاط على استحياء ذهبنا الى السوق
المركز الخضر والفاكهه في ضاحيه في ضاحيه
كانها خاليا لكن بعض التجار وبعض
المزارعين اثروا ان ان يخاطروا ان يقامروا
ان ياتوا الى السوق مع حركه بسيطه لكنهم
من ان لا تريد انه لا توجد قوه شرائيه
وذلك بسببين الوضع الامني وعدم قدره الناس
على الحركه
في الشوارع الرئيسيه اضافه الى نفاذ
النقود
من جيوب المواقع وطبعا هذا يؤدي الى سلف
وجود الثلاجات وعدم وجود الكهرباء
كل هذا يزيد من معناتهم ويجعل حركه السوق
على الرغم في خطر المساله الثانيه ان
الخدمات ما زالت متعسره في الخرطوم بحري
هذا هو اليوم الثاني عشر للاشتباكات ما
زالت مدينه الخرطوم بحري تعاني من انقطاع
المياه بسبب وجود محطه المياه الرئيسيه في
منطقه في منطقه نشطه عسكريه في اقصاء جنوب
المدينه الكهرباء ايضا لفعل المعارك
تعرضت الكثير من خطوط الضغط العالي
للتلف ولا توجد حتى الان اطقم لصيانه هذه
الخطوط بسبب الوضع الامني المتردي الجانب
الصحي ايضا المستشفيات خرجت من الخدمه وما
زال المستشفى الدولي صامد يقدم خدماته ضمن
نقصه ايضا حاد للكوادر الطبيه نقص حاد
للمشاهدات الطبيه ونقص حاد ايضا
وشحث المياه كل هذه الامور مرشحه للتفاهم